and what is happening demi Burnett and
Christian Haggerty are calling it quit
which is so beautiful I was so shocked
the bachelor in paradise stars announced
the end of their engagement on Thursday
via Instagram with Demi writing with a
heavy heart full of love for one another
we have decided it is best for us take a
step back from our relationship
Christian posted a similar statement
saying quote we will forever be proud of
the impact our love story has made and
we hope it has helped others feel more
accepted and confident within themselves
Demi and Christian were Bachelor
nation's first same-sex relationship
their historic proposal aired during the
season six finale of paradise
Haggerty of course
but with their romance came a lot of
scrutiny especially from bachelor eleven
Tanner Tolbert who told ET quote Demi is
being fully hypocritical and I have 100%
heard for multiple people that she
planned an engagement but Demi also told
ET back in August that those claims were
untrue they weren't there they don't
know the story everyone saw exactly how
it happened you saw that on TV
it wasn't pre-planned in fact once
paradise was over Demi admitted she was
looking forward to committing to
Christian long-term I just always not
been a fan of committing I like to do
whatever I want to do and I like to have
fun and you know just not really commit
to anything as simple as a lunch plan
with someone but whenever you need
someone who makes you want to change
that I and that's why I appreciated for
me it was really telling and it made me
excited to commit where I was before I
was terrified of it and although that
you are no longer together they have
forever made an impact on The Bachelor
franchise you know I've said before like
I don't want to be the one to carry the
torch of how bachelor nation or bachelor
franchise should like react to all this
kind of stuff I think that it just will
happen naturally hopefully everything
will just be normalized you know won't
be like oh the queer couple would be
like oh the couple
[Music]